Special privileges for me to welcome all
of you to fins first event besides
illusion,
challenging the way we see marine
sustainability is also my great pleasure
to welcome our two speakers this
evening,
Dr.
Arthur Hanson and Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
I'll be speaking a little bit more about
each of these gentlemen later on in the
program.
Um,
but what I would like to say now is from
my experience working with Dr.
Peterson and from what I've seen and
heard about Dr.
Arthur Hansen is there to true
renaissance men.
And we are very excited to have him here
this evening.
So before I get to our speakers,
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
Finn.
Finn is not your conventional
environmental organization.
All of our executive members have a
background in psychology as opposed to
engineering,
environmental studies or biology.
Now this leads to some special benefits
that we have.
I'm going to tell you about three
different,
oh well the special benefits are that,
um,
we can use our knowledge of the brain,
emotion and behavior to develop
innovative angles on how to publicize
the problem of marine life decimation.
So I'm going to tell you about three
different psychological concepts that
we've tried to integrate into our
advertising over the past couple of
months.
So the first is that images of cute
animals induced positive emotion and
narrow attentional focus.
That's probably not what you were
expecting to see fred.
The fish doesn't quite do it for you,
does he?
So we had to be a little bit creative.
We had to approach this problem that
fish and their appearance don't really
draw that fuzzy emotion from you that
you really want to help them out.
That's probably a lot better.
So we took the approach that if,
I don't know if any of you have pets,
but you knew that when their food bowls
bull,
they're pretty happy.
Now if you take that food away,
like for example,
if fish were to suddenly be gone,
which is one of their food sources,
not so happy,
now you add a slogan to it and there you
go.
That's one of our first advertisements.
So the second concept that I'm going to
go over is one that we've actually
borrowed from social psychology
research.
And that's something that's called the
door in the face technique.
So the gist of this technique is that
you initially make a large request from
an individual that's probably going to
be shut down.
Okay?
That's probably going to be the answer
that you're going to get.
So then you follow up this request with
a much smaller,
more reasonable one.
So the behind that is that an individual
is more likely to agree to the second
more reasonable request.
What is preceded by an outlandish one
versus has it had it been asked on its
own?
So the final concept that I'm going to
go over,
it's going to require a little bit of
background knowledge,
which I'm going to discuss and it's an
angle that we decided to take about the
health benefits that you receive when
you ingest fish or possibly fish oil.
Now I imagine that many of you know who
this is.
This is Tsai.
Uh,
he's best known for his dancing Gangnam
style.
If you don't know him,
you can ask your students on Monday or
potentially your children tonight.
They're very familiar with him.
So gangnam style is essentially a,
well,
it refers to a district in Seoul,
South Korea,
and the people who live there,
they have a very affluent lifestyle and
they achieve this wealth pretty much
overnight.
They didn't exactly have to work for.
So because of this,
it's often related to this aphorism with
great power comes great responsibility
because of the fact that they didn't
have to work for their wealth and it
came overnight.
They don't really have a sense of their
social responsibility.
So we decided to take this and related
to fish.
When it comes to eating fish,
we're all live in Gangnam style.
Basically what this means is that we
were born into a world that has oceans
that were for this great resource.
It was,
we were rich with fish,
but because of this we didn't really
develop at the same time,
that sense of responsibility that we
have to maintain our oceans and maintain
their since sustainability.
So now to the psychological concept is
the offer is and that we decided to use
it wasn't enough.
We wanted to take it one step further.
That's what we're always doing are
really,
really pushing.
So when you eat fish it helps with early
brain development and the prevention or
treatment of brain related problems.
So again,
referring to the food chain like we did
before,
how cats they fish.
We had to think who really wants a good
healthy brain zombies Zambizi brains and
they want them to be good as opposed to
unhealthy.
And we're lucky because in Toronto we
have a lot of zombies.
So you add that to the fact that people
like to dance Gangnam style.
And now just to summarize and make sure
that you're following me,
I have zombies who need good brains and
because of that they need fish.
You add that to dancing gangnam style.
You add that to the aphorism that we
developed about fish and uh,
how we're all living Gangnam style and
the next logical progression that we
were going to do.
Zombies dancing,
gangam style,
growing fish shirts with the catch
phrase at the end.
Now you'd be surprised to know that we
were actually beating to the punch.
There was already a Zombie,
the dances,
Gangnam style and he does a pretty good
Michael Jackson and Elvis Presley as
well.
So we had to we this idea,
but on a serious,
no.
Um,
this truly has been one of the most
rewarding but challenging projects I've
had the opportunity to work on.
You soon learn that one 10th of the
battle is pulling together the correct
data.
The rest is communication and finding
ways to make people listen.
Something that I quickly learned while
growing up and trying to get my parents
to see things my way is that everyone
has a different perspective and way of
communicating that we all may speak a
particular language when it comes to
explaining a problem or inspiring
action.
Different things make sense and push
different people.
For some it is art such as image or
dance.
For others as it is an equation or a
graph.
For some it is comedy and even others.
Reading and logic is fin school to use
all of these mediums to raise public
awareness about the decimation of marine
life.
Then with the help with every believer,
we want to inspire change in Canada's
ocean management policy.
Now this is something that we do not
plan to do by ourselves either.
We hope to create links not only between
departments within the University of
Toronto,
but also between all forms of
postsecondary institutions across
Canada,
the arts and design schools as well as
science and research institutions.
In this way,
we can reach out not only to communities
geographically across Canada,
but also to the communities of
likeminded reasoning.
So on that note,
I would like to introduce now our first
speaker,
Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
He earned his phd in psychology at
Mcgill University and following his post
doctor doctoral fellowship at Mcgill's
Douglas Hospital,
served as a professor of psychology at
Harvard.
Four years later,
he came to the University of Toronto
where he is a professor with two main
areas of study,
the psychology of belief and the
assessment and improvement of
personality.
His work has been supported by all three
of the main Canadian granting agencies
as well as the Rotman Business School
Center for integrative thinking.
He has authored and coauthored over 70
scientific articles including one book
maps of meaning the architecture of
belief and soon to be a second 42 Dr.
Peterson holds multiple order and
teaching awards,
including a nomination for the Levinson
teaching prize at a Harvard in 1998 and
nominations by Tvo as one of Ontario's
best university lectures each year from
2005 to 2008 in addition to his clinical
practice,
Dr.
Peterson serves as a business consultant
and executive coach for senior partners
of large law firms in Toronto and is the
vice president of a personality
assessment and remediation company.
He's also a frequent guest panelist on
Tvo is the agenda and a popular source
of information for other TV shows,
radio programs,
and printed articles.
Please welcome a man who through the
years has inspired thousands of students
to pursue their dreams and instilled the
belief and the members of fin that we
can accomplish anything,
so why not immediately started trying
[inaudible] thanks Christine.
Anyways,
it looks to me like that's what we're
facing over the next few decades.
It's kind of an evocative phrase.
This,
he seems empty anyways because of course
you can't see what's beneath the
surface,
but before the depredations of people,
it was an amazing resource.
I started to learn about this and I'm
going to walk you through what I learned
because I think it's a reasonable way of
introducing everyone to the basic
elements of familiarity that are
necessary to understand what's happening
in the oceans.
I guess sometimes I've noticed that it's
useful when you're teaching people not
to know a lot more than your audience
does because if you start to develop
great expertise in an area,
then you forget what people don't know
and it's easy to speak about things that
aren't easy to fall on.
You shouldn't have any problem with that
tonight because as I said,
I'm a relative beginner in this area and
a lot of the things I learned were
really quite obvious things,
especially in retrospect,
but,
um,
I didn't know them.
I got an opportunity to start
familiarizing myself with this
particular issue because I was fortunate
enough to work with the Canadian
subcommittee,
um,
that the secretary general of the UN set
up about three years ago on the
secretary general was interested in
producing a report and this is the final
report.
Resilient people are resilient planet.
And it was sort of a followup to the
1992 Brundtland Commission,
which was the first real worldwide
attempt to bring some order and
intelligence to ecological issues,
some with a certain degree of success.
Now that was followed up in Brazil in
2012 with an ecological slash economic
meeting.
That wasn't precisely a raving success,
but this was the document that served as
lead up to the 2012 20th anniversary of
the,
of the Brundtland Commission.
And the reason I was asked to serve on
this committee was because the people
who ran it,
it was headed by Jim ball silly who ran
Raymond Corporation.
The people who ran it didn't think that
the underlying narrative of the report
was appropriate for the modern day.
In some sense it,
it sort of felt like it had been written
in 1984,
which is actually quite a long time ago
now.
Um,
there was a lot of north versus south
ideology in it.
Um,
an ideology that's less relevant now
that the less developed world is
developing at an incredible rate and
there was a lot of left versus right
ideology and it when it seems more
appropriate in the modern world to know
that problems of this magnitude have to
be solved by everyone regardless of
their political orientation.
And,
uh,
there was a lot of underlying the
underlying implicit idea that the planet
would be better off without the people
on it,
which is not a position that I hold and
I,
which I also think is a dangerous one to
promote.
And so I had the opportunity to rephrase
the underlying structure of the document
to some degree,
to the degree that that's possible when
you're working with multiple committees,
but,
but at least in part to stress some of
the really great things that people have
accomplished over the last two decades.
And I want to start with that because
it's necessary to put things in context.
You know,
I mean,
we're assaulted by apocalypse is all the
time.
I mean,
I'm 50 years old now and I mean I can,
I've lived through at least five
probable apocalypse is none of which
thankfully it occurred.
And the problem with that is that it's
easy to get apocalypse overdose and in a
sense and to feel that you're assaulted
by catastrophes from so many directions
that the only logical thing to do is to
ignore them.
Now I don't think that's true because
people have been getting their act
together in multiple dimensions and
quite remarkable weights.
And so I'll detail some of those.
In 1970 approximately 900 of the 3.5
billion people currently alive,
we're hungry.
The same number were hungry in 2008
however,
the population had doubled during that
period.
So the proportion of hungry people have
during the most rapid expansion of human
population in history.
That's pretty remarkable.
And it's not what people pr predicted
because the most dire environmental
estimates in the late 1960s were
predicated on the idea that by the year
2000,
with the six or 7 billion people that
were likely to be around it,
there would be widespread starvation.
Quite the contrary.
People are better fed than they ever
have been.
In fact,
there are more obese people in the world
now than there are hungry people,
which is really some kind of
accomplishment even though it's,
you know,
damning in a sense with faint praise.
Um,
in 1981 about 52% of the world's
population,
2 billion of 4.5
lived under the new World Bank,
poverty cutoff estimates of a dollar and
quarter a day.
By 2005,
that finger had decreased to 25% and
current estimates indicate that this
figure is moving down where it's at 2%
of the total world population per year,
assuming one point percent which is
conservative,
the percentage below the poverty cutoff
by now may have fallen to 15%.
So that's a staggering achievement.
The proportion of people living in
poverty in East Asian Pacific has
decreased by more than 50% since 1990
and this after rates and already have in
the previous two decades,
lifespan has increased dramatically.
We have the spectacle in Africa now
where I read the economist a week and a
half ago that there are enough cell
phones in Africa now so that three out
of four people have them.
And that's brought tremendous economic
advantages to the people of Africa,
a contributing part to the fact,
which is almost impossible to believe
that the sub Saharan African countries
are now the fastest growing economies in
the world.
And so we're actually in a position
maybe for the first time in human
history where the only reason for
starvation and hunger is political.
So there's also been a staggering
decrease in the number of antidem
democratic or totalitarian states over
the last 30 years.
And it's partly because in some sense
the whole idea of totalitarianism,
whether it's on the left or the right,
has lost its essential validity.
Even the dictators themselves don't
believe in there in the justifications
they put forward for their abuse of
power.
And so what we've seen happening is
horrible governments toppling one after
another,
which really a miraculous rate,
you know,
and that's all on top of the collapse of
the Soviet Union and the demolition of
the Iron Curtain and all these things
that for someone my age seem absolutely
miraculous,
not,
not dimension of course the opening up
of China.
So you know,
three cheers for the human race,
it's pretty damn good that we've managed
to put those sorts of successes
together.
Mean the UN had a millennium goal in
2000 to cut poverty in the world by
half,
by 2015 they figured they hit that by
2011 so you know,
these things or just any,
any,
any person with any sense would regard
that fundamentally as miraculous.
It's,
it's massive economic productivity
increases combined with massive
population increases.
I mean,
so you know,
it's not all gloomy and so the UN and
the initial UN report had virtually none
of that in there.
I think that's a real mistake.
You don't,
because human beings,
you know,
we've got waste management problems and
there's a lot of us and we eat a lot.
But you know,
we're also trying as hard as we can to
put things together as fast as we can.
You know,
all things considered,
there's always unreasonable people.
But you know,
for a bunch of creatures that only
separated from chimpanzees 7 million
years ago,
you know,
we're not doing that bad.
We didn't even understand oceanic be
called the g at all,
you know,
for acceptance into the last hundred
years.
So we are trying to learn things as fast
as we can.
So you know,
credit where credit's due and there's a
lot of credit do.
And it's also really important not to
make the case that everything's terrible
because it's,
it's a,
it's a low resolution,
thoughtless case,
you know,
when you have to concentrate on things
and differentiate between them.
So you know,
the difference between things that are
problems and things that aren't because
of everything's a problem.
Well you might as well just sit at home
and drink gin because there's nothing
you can do about it.
But you know,
the truth of the matter is,
is that when we put our minds together,
we can actually fix things pretty fast.
And part of the necessity that precedes
fixing things is to become informed
enough so that you understand at least
to some minimal degree what you're
talking about.
So I'm hoping that to some minimal
degree,
I know what I'm talking about him.
If I'm not,
I'm hoping that Arthur Hansen,
who's a real expert on these matters,
will correct me so well,
what's still bad in the world?
Well,
corruption still bad and it's a,
it's a cause of suffering that's
definitely under addressed,
I think often for political reasons.
And there's no doubt that we have a
pollution problem.
And I would say that's basically a waste
management problem.
It's the kind of problem that faces
really it a any creature because all
creatures have to deal with their waste.
And of course,
maybe we produce a bit more of it than
we should because we're pretty smart and
we build lots of things.
But you know,
it is part and parcel of living in a
universe where the primary forces
thermodynamic deterioration,
you know,
it's a hell of a thing to fight.
So it's not because we're innately evil
that we produce byproducts.
It's because life is very complex and
difficult to sustain and we want to live
longer.
No wonder and we'd rather than everyone
didn't suffer any more than they had to.
And that's probably a good thing too.
So we've got our reasons.
However,
when I was going through all of this,
you know,
there was a couple of things that really
stuck out for me and one of them was the
oceanic problem because,
well,
there was a bunch of reasons.
The first was because I thought the data
indicating that what we were doing was
damaging was really in controvertible as
opposed to many of the issues that you
hear about from time to time or maybe
constantly,
it's very,
very clear that we're overfishing and
overfishing dramatically and that we're
doing other things to the oceanic
environment that are definitely not in
our medium or longterm interest to say
nothing about the creatures themselves.
I also thought that oceanic the oceanic
management problem was an appropriate
problem to consider from a more
practical perspective.
I mean,
I thought a lot about global warming and
um,
I'm not going to talk much about global
warming because that isn't what I'm here
to talk about.
But one of the things I did realize
about global warming rapidly was that
the error in the estimates of the likely
warming of the planet over the next 60
years are so large,
even if they're done by the best
scientists,
they're so large that even if we stopped
using anything that produced carbon
dioxide now,
we would never know if that actually
helped.
And when I looked at that,
I thought,
well,
how in the world are you going to sell
something like that?
Even if it works,
you can't tell if it worked.
Plus,
you know that the time course of
improvement is over multiple decades and
everyone uses hydro carbon energy.
So it's a real killer to try to address.
It seemed to me that it was more logical
in some ways to focus on problems.
It had a shorter horizon and some what
more immediate returns because that way
you can tell if all the effort that
you're putting into solving the problem
is actually having some sort of positive
consequence and the oceanic management
problems seem to fit into that too.
It was wasn't intractable,
it wasn't a problem that was rapidly
disappearing on its own.
Like world poverty seems to be,
I don't think you could speed that up
and the disappearance of poverty any
more than it's been sped up,
it's sorta hit maximum improvement.
So it's sort of falls into the category
of solvable problem with potentially
proper interventions.
The other thing is,
as far as I can tell,
there's no losers to fixing this.
You know,
the,
the oceanic mismanagement problem is of
such magnitude with the exception of
certain species that if we keep up our
rate of fishing for the next 20 years,
there's not going to be an awful lot
left.
And that's not going to be very good for
the large corporations that you know,
that,
that make their economic living off the
oceans.
And it's can be a real hard on us if we
want to eat.
And then of course there's the loss of
the beauty and the diversity and,
and also the potential to truly
transform the nature of the ecosystems
of the ocean in a way that really won't
be good.
I mean,
our planet's covered two thirds by
oceans and that's a lot.
And like we're messing with them in a
really serious way.
And part of the reason for that is,
you know,
fish or fish and they've got scales and
they're not that brainy and we're going
after them with like 21st century
technology.
You know,
we use planes to spark them and sonar to
find out where they are and,
and you like ultrasonic mapping to,
to,
to check out the structure of the bottom
of the ocean and massive nets and like
those bloody things don't have a chance.
And that's not so good.
You know,
it's inappropriate use of technology.
Now.
There's some real reasons for it.
Now,
as I said,
I'm a layperson and I read a lot.
I probably read it called 40 books and a
whole pile of papers on this topic and
others and some of them were really
helpful and these are some of them.
The end of the line is a great book and
these are very straightforward books to
read there.
They're very engaging,
unnatural history to see.
I love that the most important fish in
the sea that's about this little herring
like fish that lives off the Atlantic
coast called the Manhattan,
which is kind of an in an inedible oily
beast of a herring.
And it it at least one time numbered in
the hundreds of billions.
It might've been the most plentiful
animal on the surface of the planet,
maybe outnumbering all the other fish
and it's at the very bottom of the food
chain and people can't really eat it,
but everything else does.
Uh,
one of the things we're doing with the
Manhattan,
which seems,
you know,
really not all that bright is vacuuming,
vacuuming them up,
like Mr.
Burns from the simpsons and grinding
them into fish fertilizer and spreading
them all over the ground.
You know,
when we have all sorts of other ways of
making fertilizer.
And so,
you know,
we're stripping the whole bottom of the
food chain out of the Atlantic coast.
And a lot of that seems to have to do
with political corruption in the eastern
US states.
So it's a,
it's a remarkable book,
cod.
I love that too.
Mark Kurlansky,
he's a great author and you know,
reading about the devastation to the cod
fishery in the east coast is just enough
to make the bottom fall out of your
heart because it was so damn dumb.
You know,
everybody knew it was coming and people
pretended that it wasn't an we
devastated rich resource that was really
the pride of the country and also a
mainstay of,
of the world economy for five,
600 years,
you know?
So it's a great book and I'm showing you
those books because that source material
for a lot of what I'm going to tell you
now,
the first thing I learned about the
oceans was that the oceans aren't that
big,
not when you're talking about what lives
in them.
Because the ocean is actually have two
kinds of structure and one structure
they call the pelagic zone and it only
extends 50 miles from the shore.
So it's like this little skinny,
you know,
offshoot of the continents essentially
maybe a note as the continental shelf.
And it's only about 500 feet deep.
Now that's important because because
it's only that deep light can get to the
bottom from the sun.
And so you need light for things to
grow,
especially plants.
And if plants can't grow then the
animals can't eat anything and then
there aren't any animals.
So it turns out that all the,
all the life fundamentally,
you know,
with,
with a bit of an exception is within 50
miles from shore.
And so,
and,
and in these areas that are only,
you know,
500 feet deeper last.
Now if you look at this map,
the light blue areas,
there are the pelagic zone.
And you know,
they look pretty big up in the Arctic.
Remember this is all stretched out
because it's not a very intelligent
projection,
but all the dark blue stuff,
man,
that's deep,
two miles deep on average.
And it can be 11,000
feet deep and places.
And the problem with that is it's really
dark.
No light gets down there.
It's really cold.
It's not much above freezing.
It's really high pressure,
like higher pressure than the surface of
Venus.
And so it's not that hospitable for life
and there's not a lot around there.
And you know,
the problem with that,
at least in part as well,
a,
that's most of the ocean and be,
it's mostly empty,
but because it's cold and dark,
the things that do live there,
well they're not very well understood,
but they also grow very fast.
So if you do fish them and who we are
fishing them,
then you know,
you fish them and it's like harvesting
the trees that grow up in the Arctic,
you know,
they take forever to grow back.
So,
and as we fished out the pelagic zone,
which were,
which were doing at a fairly rapid rate,
we've increasingly turned to the
neuritic zone with,
especially with trawlers that can now
reach 2000 meters down to the bottom of
the ocean.
And,
um,
you know,
it's not high quality food.
Generally speaking.
But the problem too is we don't
understand it well and it seems quite
easy to devastate.
So anyway,
so that's a useful thing to know is that
there really isn't that much food
bearing ocean and that a lot of the
planet is sorta covered by water that's
too dark,
deep and cold to be of a lot of use.
Here's the things that really broke my
heart.
I think reading this,
um,
because one of the things that these
books taught me was just how much there
was before we took it.
And like I said,
I'm not an anti human in any way,
but the way this struck me was that it
was a catastrophic aesthetic and,
and,
and spiritual loss,
a loss of,
of the absolute bounty of the planet and
this sort of thing that that evokes in
the viewer or the experience or the same
sort of thing that maybe is evoked when
you look up at the sky and see the vast
array of stars sort of spread out before
you was the magnificence of nature.
And we're denying ourselves at the
privilege of experiencing that
increasingly.
So let me tell you what it was like when
the Europeans first came to North
America.
You want to remember that this is even
after the native Americans had done a
fair bit of fishing and also after the
Europeans had already pretty much fished
out their water's completely sturgeon
law.
Sturgeon's a prehistoric fish.
It's been around about 60 million years
or so,
and they get really long and big.
They get so big you have to haul them
out of rivers.
With Oxen,
they can wait 1200 pounds and there are
hardly any on the Atlantic coast
anymore.
I don't know if there are any,
there's some steel in northwestern
Canada.
They live in the Fraser River,
for example.
Um,
this was the potomac river in 1760
potomac.
I guess sturgeon and shad are in such
prodigious numbers that in one day,
within the space of two miles,
only some gentlemen in canoes caught
about 600 of the former that was
sturgeon with hooks,
which they let down to the bottom and
drew up at adventure when they perceive
them to rub against the fish and of the
ladder.
Shad about 5,000
had been caught in one single hole of
the net,
so it was possible to cute cat 600
sturgeon in one day.
I'd want imagine that 600 sturgeon are
caught now in the whole world in a year.
Alloway for herring in 1728 this is from
William Byrd when they spawn all streams
and waters are completely filled with
them and one might believe when he sees
such terrible amounts of them that there
was as great a supply of herring as
there is water in words.
It is unbelievable indeed indescribable
as a whole so incomprehensible what
quantity is found there.
One must be hold oneself.
There are medieval pictures of the
herring run near the coast where people
would put a Hallberg,
which was a kind of double headed ax
with on a on a pole in the water and it
would stand because there were so many
herring around at the hearing themselves
were packed in so tightly that the thing
would stay up in the water will you
would the hell of it is not much unlike
a place or turd bought some being two
yards long and one wide and a foot
thick.
The plenty of better fish.
So they had plenty of better fish than
halibut.
When the Europeans first came to North
America make them little esteemed except
the head and fins,
which studer baked is very good.
These halibut's be little set by while
Bass Bass is in season thorn back and
skates is given to the dogs being not
counted worth addressing in many places.
You should also know that when the
Europeans first came to North America,
salmon and lobster fell in the same
category.
So there were laws in New England about
how many lobster you could feed.
Convicts are slaves in a week because it
was,
you know,
it was like feeding them bugs as far as
the new Englanders were concerned.
You know,
in salmon was so plentiful,
it was basically a junk fish.
So these things that we now regard
essentially is delicacies,
especially why wild salmon were there.
An absolutely unbelievable numbers.
So I lived in Boston for a little while
and I used to go up to the coast.
There is a place there called Cape Band,
which was up where the whaling
communities used to be because it was a
big whaling area and we used to go to
this beautiful beach that was like seven
miles long and 300 yards wide and it was
an absolutely pristine,
gorgeous place and made the history of
the area,
recounts the nate,
what happened to the beach after nor
easters and ignore Easter is like a
hurricane except it's the northern
version of a hurricane.
And he said after our good nor Easter,
which happened around Boston,
pretty often the beach there would be
covered with shellfish and other fish,
three feet deep and a hundred yards wide
and seven miles long.
So why after there was a nor'easter,
the whole area would reek for months
because of all the rotting fish and
self,
shellfish.
I went to Cape and to the beach one time
after a nor eastern walked about three
miles,
I found one starfish,
an empty lobster trap and a half dead
horseshoe crab.
And that was it.
And normally walking on that beach,
there was nothing at all.
So that's the degree to which the area
had been essentially devastated.
Um,
priest,
Andrei Bernaul dads with Christopher
Columbus throat,
that voyage,
they saw that there were many turtles
and very large,
but in those 20 leagues they saw very
many more for the sea was thick with
them and they were of the largest,
so numerous that it would seem that the
ships would run aground on them.
And we're as if bathing in them,
the Indians value them highly in regard
them as very good to eat unhealthy and
savory.
Figured there were something on the
neighborhood of two to 400 million
turtles in the Caribbean and they're
pretty much all gone.
Uh,
sea otters from San Francisco to the
Santa Clara estuary.
The ground appeared covered with black
sheets due to the great quantity of
orders which were there,
the disappearance of orders,
because they were almost completely
wiped out,
eliminated kelp forests because the
order's eight,
the urchins,
which grains don't.
The Kelp and removing the Kelp forest
swiped out steller sea cow,
which was a 30 foot marine animal
similar to the manatee,
except much larger.
It was wiped out the content along
habitat and hunting,
uh,
28 years after it's identification by
Europeans,
um,
from California,
a late 1850s,
a thousand gray whales a day passed
along the shore between December 15th
and February 1st.
So there are valid reports from all over
the world before the whaling industry
really kicked in of whales being about
as common as porpoises are now when you
see them swarming around the front of
boats.
So there were whales absolutely
everywhere.
So you imagine that a thousand today for
a,
for basically a three month period.
So pairing 1776 when the main body has
arrived,
it's breadth and depth is such as to
alter the very appearance of the ocean.
It is divided into distinct columns of
five or six miles in length and three or
four broad,
well the water before them curls up as
if forced out of it's been sometimes
they st for this base of 10 or 15
minutes.
Then rising into the surface and a great
weather,
reflective variety of splendid colors
like a field be spangled with purple
golden easier.
The whole water seems alive and it seems
so blocked with them to a great distance
that the numbers seems inexhaustible.
The,
there were so many turtles swimming
towards the islands in the Caribbean is
that when the sailors used to get lost
in the fog,
if they were close enough,
they could,
they could sail to land by hearing the
turtles splash in the water.
Along with the herring,
the herring schools of great magnitude.
There were immense number of creditors
because of course the herring is a
primary food for other fish.
And so there were massive schools of
sharks and so on that would come along,
feed on them,
had doc from Goldsmith and 18,
10 the annually visit the British coast
and shows that sometimes extend along
the shore a hundred miles in length and
300 miles in breadth
in 1855 43 fishing schooners from
beverly,
Massachusetts caught more cod south of
Nova Scotia on the Scotian shelf.
So these are just sailing ships than the
entire Canadian fleet caught there in
1999,
six years later,
34 schooners landed more card on the
Maine coast between Penobscot Bay in
Grand Manan that we're caught in the
entire Gulf of Maine from Cape Cod to
Canada in 1999.
So,
well,
if you read those books that I showed
you,
they're just full of accounts of
precisely.
That sorta makes painful reading.
You know,
there's Kurlansky also wrote a book
called,
uh,
the big oyster,
which is about New York.
And he talked about what Chesapeake Bay
used to be like.
Uh,
Kurlansky claims that the average sized
oyster 300 years ago was as big as a
dinner plate and had to be cut into four
pieces before it could be water.
And so chesapeake bay was an absolutely
staggering masterpiece of natural plenty
and it's pretty much been reduced to
nothing as well.
So it makes pretty painful reading.
And one of the things I also learned
about this,
and I'll talk about this a little bit
later,
is you know,
when you hear estimates of fish stock
depletion,
you hear things like 95% since the
beginning of the 20th century.
But lots of these writers claimed that
the fish stocks had already been reduced
by 95% or more by the beginning of the
20th century.
So we're looking at a 95% reduction in a
95% reduction.
So you know,
that kind of hurts.
Now there's a lot of reasons for this.
One of them is called the tragedy of the
Commons.
And the tragedy of the Commons is,
well,
imagine that there's a field on which
anybody can graze their sheep.
While the logical thing to do is to get
your sheep out there and let them eat
all the grass before the next guy gets
his sheep out there.
And he told the groks.
Right.
And so the tragedy of the Commons is
that when there's no fixed ownership of
a resource,
it makes sense economically for the
person who gets first access to the
resource to take as much of it as they
can.
Because anything they leave,
at least in principle,
it's going to be taken by someone else.
And historically,
until at least 1978 the open ocean was
only seven miles off shore.
That's where the,
where the national jurisdiction and did
it.
The rest of the sea was regarded as,
you know,
a free charactery in a sense.
So people can take whatever they wanted
and you know,
you can see that as a legal and a
structural problem.
So that's one of the main contributors,
another contributor right now to,
to the continued decimation of the
world's fish stocks.
And one of the things that makes
regulation difficult is what's being
described as technological creep.
So he say,
it might say,
well,
you know,
maybe you can limit your boat to 40 the
boats that are allowed to fish to 40
feet in length or something like that.
Instead of these massive factory boats
that go out and you know,
sit on the ocean for months and vacuum
up everything in their trail.
The problem with technological creek,
which sounds like a,
you know,
maybe some kind of computer programmer
who's looking lurking in the bushes,
is that even your 40 foot keeps getting
outfitted with better and better
technology,
right?
Because as you know,
how fast our technology increases and so
you can have the same size boat that you
had 10 years ago and the things like 10
times as deadly as it was because you
know,
you're outfitted with the latest gear
and you can understand why the fishermen
are driven to that.
But it's another structural problem that
that adds to this general overall
problem.
Um,
the use of this sort of space age
technology has had a pretty catastrophic
consequence too.
So,
um,
we're doing something that call,
let's see,
I've got to,
yeah,
fishing down the food chain.
And so the way the food chains are set
up is there's like,
you know,
plankton at the bottom and neat whatever
they can get their little hands on.
And they're often a,
you don't actually have handsome,
you know,
they also useful to synthesis and
they're there at the bottom of the food
chain is billions of the things being
whales,
eat them,
some whales and then you know,
little fish eat those.
And then bigger fish eat the little fish
and bigger fish eat,
you know,
the medium size fish and so on,
all the way up to things like sharps and
swordfish and tuna and,
and human beings.
Now what we're basically doing,
we tend to like the fish that are higher
up on the,
on the food chain.
So we,
we tend to like the taste of predatory
fish cause they're hard muscle.
And now the problem with that is that
the higher you are,
you are up in the food chain,
the fewer there can be of you in part
because you know your,
your primary sources of food or limited
by this,
by this pyramid phenomena.
As we've got better and better from a
technological perspective at catching
fish.
What's happened is we keep,
we are fishing down the food chain.
We go from the great big fish at the
top,
like the sharks,
about 70 million a year of which right
now are killed for shark fin soup.
And that's,
yeah,
it's a lot of sharks.
70 million a year,
you know,
we're gonna run out of sharks and no
time flat if we keep things up at that
rate.
And so we fished down the food chain,
we take the big predators first and
they're the most valuable fish.
And then we go after what they go after.
And then we go after what that fish has
gone after.
And we go out farther afield and we go
out into the deep ocean and we find
places that no one's fished before,
but we're so damn good at it now that
the time to exhaustion of the new fish
species from the time we discovered is
about 15 years.
So we can discover a new species,
which is often given,
even if it's half the inedible,
it's given a real market,
we'll name we go after it was facing
each technology and wipe it down to more
than two,
less than 85% if it's previous numbers
within 15 years,
we're really deadly.
And so,
you know,
as soon as we discover something,
plus there's so many of us that the
things in serious trouble and pretty
much no time flat
there is,
there has been a global decline in the
world's catch ever since about 1998 if
you control for Red China's data,
because the Chinese,
from what I've been able to determine,
tend to inflate their production
numbers.
I mean,
that's a standard trick and totalitarian
states.
But there are,
even though we switch our switching to
different species and,
and you know,
we're pretty damn good at that.
We haven't been able to halt the decline
in overall catch despite the fact that,
you know,
our technology is improved a lot.
We're going after other species and
that's not a good thing.
And the other thing that's really worth
noting about fish,
and this is one of the things that
convinced me that there really was a
problem was you guys might know about
the,
the bat that was made by a star,
Stanford biologist,
Paul Erlick and an economist whose name
I don't remember in about 1968 and Paul
Erlick had written this book called the
Population Bob,
where he predicted that,
you know,
we're all going to starve to death by
the year two.
And the economists always disagree with
the biologist because economists think
we're real smart and can think our way
out of everything.
And you know,
so far they've been,
you know,
reasonably right.
The biologist say,
well,
it's just a time thing.
We'll Melle Mel fussell when eventually
and who knows?
But this economist Bet Erlick that by
the year 2000 and commodity prices would
have gone down instead of up.
Cause Eric's idea was everything's
getting scarce.
So from 1968 to the year 2000 all of our
commodities which are somewhat scarce
are going to increase in price.
Well Erlick got stomped.
The commodity prices plummeted between
1968 and 2000 so the economist had them,
you know,
beat him in no uncertain terms.
But the one thing that didn't work out
that way is seafood.
I mean things like card used to be
cheap,
right?
Seafood used to be cheap fish and chips.
That was the cheapest thing you could
buy on the menu.
Well it's not like that anymore.
See food is expensive and you know
bloody well when something gets
expensive that there actually isn't that
much of it anymore.
It's a really good marker.
So you know,
we have global decline,
global catch,
declining figures,
allied with pretty hard economic data.
That fish is a lot more expensive than
it used to be.
Plus we're harvesting,
we're harvesting species that people
wouldn't have even considered edible a
hundred years ago.
I mean,
200 years ago they were complaining
about halibut and feeding it to their
dogs.
It's like that's a high quality fish by
our standards.
So there's no doubt that this is a real,
this is a real phenomenon.
And there's other awful things that
really are kind of difficult to tolerate
when you read about them.
And trawling is one of them in here.
Here's a nice description of trolling.
Um,
basically what a troll does is it's a
huge net that's put behind a really big
boat and the net is weighted down and
has rollers.
There's a bunch of different kinds of
them.
It has rollers and you put it on the
bottom of the ocean,
sort of digs down to a depth of about
eight inches.
And then you just drag the thing and you
drag it till the net fills up and well,
what does it fill up with?
Well,
whatever's down there,
coral.
Okay.
So,
especially now that they're fishing out
the deeper areas of the ocean,
all the corals coming up,
300 pound chunks of it.
Maybe they figured it takes 10,000
years to grow.
And you know that's habitat for,
for fish.
You run a trawler over an area,
there's nothing left of it.
It takes everything.
You haul it up,
what happens?
You take your 10% of the damn fish
that's in there that you want to eat and
you throw 90% back because that's what
you have to do by law.
So the bycatch,
so to speak,
which is what you don't want his 90%
back,
it goes into the water.
Now remember I showed you the
continental shelf,
there's not that much of it while we've
trolled most of it.
So in that isn't stopping in the
trawlers are getting bigger.
There's something they call the super
trawler that was heading down to despite
a lot of,
you know,
public outcry because the Australians
are fairly sensitive about this sort of
thing.
You know,
they get bigger and bigger and bigger
all the time.
And that's partly because they're,
you know,
cause they can and partly because
they're chasing and diminishing
resource.
So you imagine what would happen if you,
you know,
went through a,
a nice bit of grassland or National Park
with a net 300 feet high and it was,
you know,
drag through by tractors.
You just take everything,
trees,
deer,
Moose,
birds,
insects,
everything.
Pull out the things you can eat,
let everything else rock Jesus.
If it was happening on the land,
people would be shorting out and running
around in circles screaming.
But it's happening on the,
at the bottom of the ocean and no one
can see it.
And it's not just happening once.
There's lots of places in the North Sea
which used to be clear and is no longer
clear.
It's muddy because of the trawling,
at least in part because of the
disturbance of the ocean floor.
That place is being trolled like three
or four times.
So,
you know,
obviously that's not going to work for
very long.
So here's our,
here's the description.
Picture,
a 2000 horsepower trawler targeting
place or soul pulling,
a beam trawl mounted with a rotating
tickler with rotating tickler chains
across the featureless fans and gravels
of the southern North Sea.
The weight in troll and its chains
designed to beat flat fish out of the
sheltering mud smashes up everything.
It does not catch particularly the
burrowing animals in the sediment,
disturbing them at depths of up to six
inches.
European Union scientists have
calculated that up to 16 pounds of
marine animals are killed by being
trawls to produce one pound of
marketable soul,
sea urchins,
hermit crabs,
brittle stars and razor shells or killed
or having part of their shells opened,
made vulnerable to predators.
Starfish tend to be the survivors losing
a leg or two,
but escaping the net.
The winter and heavily traveled areas
are usually crabs which move in from
other areas to eat damaged creatures and
worms that take over from the easily
damaged by valves.
Scientists have concluded that most
parts of the southern North Sea have
been disturbed by a beam trial at least
once a year.
The damage caused by phishing is
estimated at 100,000
times greater than that of oil or gas
exploration.
So it's pretty much total devastation.
So you know,
that's kind of distressing.
Um,
and they estimate about 25% of the
world's total catch is hauled in by
trawls.
So that just doesn't seem like a
particularly intelligent way of going
about things now because the whole shelf
has been trawled and there's not a hell
of a lot left there.
They've developed trawls and can go down
to 2000 meters and 2000 meters.
You know,
that's getting to be a mile and a half.
That's,
that's close to the average depth of the
deepest part of the ocean.
Now when you go way down in the ocean,
there's not a lot there as I said,
but there are places in the ocean floor
that are seen mouths.
So they sort of poke up and when they
poke up,
currents come up to them and there's a
lot of food on the sea mount areas and
they can map those out really nicely
now.
And with the deep sea trials,
they just go over the sea mounts and
take everything that's there.
So and perceives or are also pretty
devastating,
especially when you combine them with
spotting new airplanes because the
spotting airplanes go off the coast and
they find a,
you know,
a school and then the scenes,
the savings come in and they take the
whole school.
So you know,
that's also not really particularly a
promising thing to be happening.
So then the next problematic form of
fishing seems to be maybe longline
fishing.
And so long lines are pretty much
exactly what they sound like.
They're very long fishing lines and very
long means up to 40 miles long and with
30 hooks per mile.
And so that's 1200 hooks.
And so,
you know,
they're often catching the kind of fish
that you'd like to eat.
But the catch a lot of other things too,
like tens of thousands of seabirds and
tens of thousands of turtles and all
sorts of things in sharks and all sorts
of things that you know,
will eat anything that's on a baited
hook.
So the bike catch problem with longline
fishing is also horrendous.
So that's Kinda,
that's Kinda,
you know,
miserable to apprehend as well.
And then,
you know,
there's this thing I mentioned a little
bit earlier about the Manhattan and
that's,
that,
that was a very distressing book to read
because they're the Manhattan because
they're at the bottom of the food chain
down,
you know,
near where the little fish are there.
Oh,
it Manhattan.
Interestingly enough,
our vegetarian,
most fish aren't vegetarian,
but these guys are vegetarians.
So that's what puts them at the bottom
of the food chain.
They also take a lot of garbage out of
the water because they're vegetarian.
And so if there's Algal blooms or
something like that,
which there often is because of nitrogen
runoff from fertilizers from the land
and the Manhattan,
we'll go in there and cleaned it up and
then all the other official eat them.
But they take the Manhattan out to turn
them into fertilizer.
And as I said already,
you know,
that seems to be served at least in part
by corruption in the east coast states.
They do the same thing in Denmark with
this thing called the Sandy Hill.
And it's another one of these ugly
little things that,
you know,
people wouldn't normally eat,
but everything else does.
And there's a lot of them.
They're sort of like the Manhattan,
they breed like mad,
but um,
they've been catching them,
catching those up a store and do it and
often burning them for oil.
So.
MMM.
Well,
and then there's us,
you know,
Canada,
Canada is by no means an ecological
paradise.
Like we like to pride ourselves on the
idea that,
you know,
were there sort of great north with our
massive forests in our care for the
environment.
Most of that's pretty much rubbish.
So for example,
we have a far a smaller portion of our
territory devoted to,
to national parks in the American Stu,
despite the fact that what 95% of the
country is basically uninhabited.
So that's a pretty shocking statistic.
And the Americans have done a much
better job at managing their fisheries
than us.
And you know,
we should have been shocked into what
embarrassed action in 1992 when this
happened.
So,
you know,
the cod fishery off the grand banks and
being there for 400 years and it was
really one of the world's remarkable
treasures.
And,
uh,
around before,
I guess 1978,
the,
the limit to national sovereignty I
think was seven miles.
It's far as seven miles.
I can't remember exactly what,
and you know,
the Spanner Spaniards and the Portuguese
and,
and lots of European fishing boats were
in the grand banks fishing like mad,
which of course they'd been doing for
really almost 600 years.
The Basques might've even got there
before Christopher Columbus and not told
anybody because they like to have all
those fish,
you know,
and basks they're pretty sneaky people.
So anyways,
you know,
so the Canadian government made a big
fuss about the fact that all these
foreigners were out there taking out the
card and they were part of the,
the political force that got the
national sovereignty zone extended to
200 miles off shore.
So the candidate had manage its own cod
stocks.
And of course we do it responsibly.
Well,
the first thing that happened was the
federal government modernize the
Newfoundland fishing fleet and equipped
it with,
you know,
really outstanding boats in.
The second thing that happened was we
took all the fish.
And so by net while you see what
happened by basically by 1992,
so 2 billion fish,
that's the estimate.
That's a lot of fish equal in weight to
the entire Canadian population.
And these cod man,
they were magnificent animals.
They figured the ones that were there,
um,
when the Europeans first came over to
North America or something like five
feet lane in length,
more or less on average and teeth,
three feet around.
These were big fish.
You know,
they're both the size of a person and
they came and massive,
massive schools and no one really knows
why they haven't come back.
There's,
there's a couple of hypothesis.
One is,
you know,
fish in schools are like zebras.
You don't see zebras loans,
zebras rate roaming the Serengeti,
you know,
what you see as big clumps of zebras
because they're herd animals and they
really are herd animals,
which means the herd is their
environment.
And so they can't live away from a heard
more or any less than people can.
And it looks like cod.
You're sort of like that.
And other fish that live in schools.
So for example,
one of the things that happens with cod
schools is that,
first of all,
there's a lot of subspecies of cod and
we don't know how old the schools are,
but some of the schools might be who
knows 150,000
years old as super organisms and they
seem to actually kind of know the ocean
in which they swim as a collective unit.
And so they know where to go eat and
they know where,
you know,
they know their habitat and more
importantly the card arrange themselves
in schools so that the big Carter in the
middle and the little card or sort of
outside and then the predators pick off
the little card but are useless anyways
because there are too young to breed.
So the school is structured so that the
main Carter protected second when the
card May,
they actually use the school as a mating
structure.
So they organize their mating routines
on the outside of the school structure.
And so what that implies is that if you
blow out the structure of the school,
then the God don't know what to do and
that's one potential reason they haven't
really managed to come back.
There's others,
one being perhaps that if you really
devastate a population,
then maybe you change the ecological
conditions of the environment.
Because it turns out that the way an
ecosystem sets itself up is dependent to
some degree on which creature gets their
first sort of which creature gets there
in what order.
And so if you wipe population like the
car down low enough than other animals
move in to get the niche and now set the
card can't come back.
Now there's other theories too,
you know,
some of which have to do with ocean
warming,
but the point is we've left the car loan
kind of because people are still allowed
to fish a lot more for cod than you'd
think.
We've kind of left them alone for 20
years.
And the consequences being pretty
minimal,
especially for an animal that you know,
fish,
they lay a lotta eggs.
It's not like they're,
it's not like they are,
they're not able to reproduce.
They certainly know how to do that.
So,
so,
you know,
you think we might learn something from
this,
but it doesn't really appear that we
did.
And the other thing that really struck
me as mind boggling when I was going
through this material was exactly
Canada's record,
which was so embarrassing and it was
again,
it was like a personal blow.
So in 90 then I'm going to pretty much
fold up with this.
In 1992 which was about when the cod
fishery collapsed,
the Canada promised to protect 20% of
its oceanic territory.
So the idea was to put aside chunks of
oceanic territory,
sorta like national parks,
you know,
where the animals that live there and
the ecosystems would be protected so
that they could come back.
Because you know,
fish come back pretty fast if you leave
them alone.
I read something very amusing about this
very fact.
Um,
you know,
how you heard,
and maybe this is wrong,
but I read it several places,
you know how you heard that the whole,
uh,
Gulf of Mexico oil spill was such a
catastrophe for fish?
Yeah.
Well there were more fish the year after
this field in the year before and the
reason for that is no one fished.
So that's,
you know,
that's a pretty peculiar statistic,
but it shows you two things.
A,
how many fish we take,
and B,
how damn fast the fish can come back if
you leave them alone.
The same thing happened in the North Sea
in World War II was pretty much fished
out before World War II,
but no one was fishing during World War
II because of German u boats.
There was a lot of fish in the North Sea
again after World War II.
So leave the things alone for awhile.
They can come back.
Canada promise to protect at least 20%
of its oceanic territory by 2012 in
writing,
in a series of major international
forums where cannabis signed treaties in
1990 to 2002 2003 and 2005 so not only
did we promise,
we promised frequently and in writing
less than 1% is currently protected
despite the fact that Canada has one of
the longest international coastlines in
the world and is also home to multiple,
you know how there are ecological zones
because each little geographic area has
its own peculiar characteristics.
And so really what you need is you need
to set aside a protected area that are
sort of representative and have all
these different ecological zones.
And we have plenty of those ecological
zones.
Zero action.
1% of our oceanic territory is
protected.
That's it.
And you can fish in 95% of that.
So what we've done in the aftermath of
the great cod catastrophe looks to me to
be pretty much absolutely nothing.
And what's weird about that,
and at least in part,
I mean Kevin is a complicated place,
but the Australians have actually
protected 20% of their oceanic area and
have promised 20% more recently.
And they actually seem to mean it,
which is about a third as much territory
as Australia actually has.
So it is actually possible to set aside
what are essentially national parks in
the,
in the ocean and let the damn fish come
back.
And in principle at least,
that would also be good for the
fishermen because they can hang around
the edges of the parks and you know,
the fish don't know where the boundaries
are and they can scoop them up once they
breed again.
So it's a rather cataclysmic and
staggering Sagat of insane
mismanagement.
And you know,
if it's not,
there's not much point in pointing the
finger one place or another because you
know,
it's pretty much everybody's fault.
But it sure seems to me to be one of
those things that you got to think about
as being odd.
It's,
it's,
it's hauntingly foolish because all of
that could be there.
And why wouldn't that be a good thing?
And you know,
if there was the political will in
Canada,
it could be done because other countries
have done it.
And for some reason this is just not an
on the radar issue.
Even though it's a real issue,
this is actually happening.
It's really not good.
It's happening a lot.
It's going to get worse.
We're not going to have a lot of fish to
eat.
The oceans are going to be a pretty
barren and dismal place and we could
actually do something about it.
So,
so that's why I decided to do this talk,
even though I don't really know a lot
about the oceans,
you know,
I didn't seem to me that the situation.
And so he's dangerous talking about
things when you sort of know something
and most of the adult.
But it seems to me that the situation
with the oceans is so obviously not good
that you actually don't have to be an
expert to notice.
And so what can be done about it?
Well,
you know,
the only,
I think the marine protected areas are a
good idea.
It looked,
you know that we have examples of
countries doing it and it seems to work.
Everyone's already figured out that it's
a pretty good idea.
With regards to national parks on land,
no one seems to really dispute that.
Although we know we could have some more
national parks.
So what's the big problem about having
them out in the ocean?
You know,
and to preserve some of the coastline,
to let the fish have a fighting chance.
Unless this,
we don't want to have them around,
you know,
and what we're facing in some ways while
they're starting to process jelly fish
for food,
because as we get rid of the fish that
the whole ecosystem starts to turn back
to what it was like 400 million years
ago before there were any fish and there
were lots of invertebrates and you know,
we could have an ocean full of
invertebrates and I hear they press up
into hockey stick hockey pucks size
disks pretty nicely.
They don't have a lot of taste.
And I suppose you'd have to be a pretty
good chef to make them animal,
but we probably won't run out of
jellyfish during our life.
So I dunno,
maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea to pen
and note to your mp or to the,
to the Minister of fisheries or,
and just note that,
you know,
destroying a resource that we could
actually enjoy aesthetically and
practically w destroying that seems to
be not in anybody's best interest and
that it's actually happening at a pretty
rapid rate.
So I guess that's partly what Finn is,
emmy out and partly why I decided to do
this talk and also to get involved in,
to invite Dr.
Hanson who's going to,
who really knows what he's talking
about,
who's going to speak next.
So we should take a 10 minute break and
then we'll return and have darker Henson
speak.
There'll be a question and answer period
at the end of the F at the end of Doctor
Hanson's talking.
Thank you.
[inaudible].